okay oh for god oh hold on one second
guys
the why we have love Wiemers imagine
watching the line while wearing or why
okay very happy
sorry jacksFilms is not just for tonight
that's gonna rip you off the hundred
it's just a complete coincidence all
right it's not that we thought we would
hit a 100 million way quicker okay the
hundreds is there for a random number
all right cool
epic March check out link description
now let's just leave your entries in us
already closed key honor leaves overall
your Keanu leave is a wonder what a
breathtaking Pokemon that's a good mean
Keanu memes still going strong week
three baby I don't want to kill a child
alright fine baby you can sleep with me
tonight
everyone like that I have a feeling
there's gonna be a lot of Minecraft
memes in here I'm very excited number
one trending game theory YouTube is
ruining kami minecraft part 1 don't do
that don't give me hope but there is
minecraft part 2 3 & 4
I think too bad gaming week is over okay
take a moment to appreciate Pierce
building skills okay from this okay to
this that's right gamers recognize real
thank you guys who said I wasn't a gamer
have you seen my house in Minecraft dude
it's got flowers on the outside are you
serious
did we hit 96 69 69 69 how did I not
notice this that's amazing that's what
we need to put on the murse oh one
percent are shaking in their boots 99
percent of people in the sub would
support a full minecraft letsplay if
this video gets a million likes I'll
bring back gaming week alright I'll make
it gaming week
supreme I painted Keanu Reeves because
he is breathtaking
beautiful when you scroll so far down
you start seeing blue shirt kid again
basically it's the YouTube algorithm
please Felix minecraft episode [ __ ]
Jesus Christ
1 million gaming week continues gaming
week supreme 1 million likes and buying
all the merch that's all I asked I don't
think that's that much to ask
boots still didn't touch the tree in the
middle and made it part of his home it
is a reminder for us to save the trees
that's right if you cut down a tree
you must plant two more that's the rules
it's all minecraft name's PewDiePie hits
iron golem Iren golem hits back
PewDiePie wow what we see okay what
Felix sees okay
alright sorry I didn't know you can't
walk over your crops I didn't know what
applies to Minecraft applies to real
life guys we have bags okay 1 million
this could be you 1 million
do you agree Felix should sleep in
another to get the secret achievement
hell yeah I need secret achievement a
new AI tool from Adobe can detect
Photoshop phases spamming pills with
tips for Minecraft telling him how much
we enjoy the series and letting him find
out how to play the game himself I'm
really glad you guys enjoyed cuz I'm
genuinely having fun too
that's epic gamer supporting gamers
gamer supporting gamers on gaming week
number one trending number one trending
beginning to see here that I like that's
just confusing I was like I swear I've
said that alright it's me
bTW pi should sleep in the nether so you
can see they're really cool Easter egg
what the hell this is Easter egg okay
fine I'll do it
minecraft part 1 8 years 8 years that's
crazy dude it's pretty cool actually
like I never thought of it like coming
back to a game you haven't played in so
long that's been continually updating
literally any mother there you go any
minecraft feature added after 2010 PD
hi what is that but there's horses in
Minecraft
oh god please stop god dammit alright
here we go again me plus the boys at 2
am looking for beans gamer approves
thanks for making it easy for me
hello Brad 1 or save please tell us how
many hours of raw footage proves a cent
of him playing Minecraft
thanks a concerned nine-year-old don't
you dare tell them don't you dare tell
them bro
mr. B's is the only youtuber I'm okay
with putting 5 ads and PewDiePie cool
I'm glad we settled my mana pool that's
awesome upvote yada yada millions oh
maybe we can plant the eggs why is there
a cactus girl listen has anyone tried
planting the eggs why would you put a
bed in the nether ok sometimes you don't
know until you try how did the first
chicken was born
well what came first the chicken or the
egg well the egg was planted then the
chicken came pills should start a
Minecraft hardcore let's play with these
guys like these guys know as much about
Minecraft than I do there's only one
person that I'll ever play Minecraft
with and it's James Charles god damnit
Angry anime girls look so cute yeah me
explaining to Felix that he shouldn't
jump on hold dirt him mining gravel with
the picking our I don't know what gravel
is what's gravel grobble grobble in
swedish glues gross oh god I'm actually
that dumb I didn't know I didn't know
never dig straight that it's literally
all my coal it's the Frog of a meme
ruined oh my god there's horses in
Minecraft village that generated near
spawn point a literal rarity am ia joke
to you see I don't how am I supposed to
know these things what do I do in the
village help me is to a lot depends on
the context dollars no pewdiepie videos
on trending yeah
I think we've been training every single
day this week yeah I kind of want to let
him go
can you do it what happens if you let a
bit friendly a reminder that there are
currently 69 days till dr. field turned
69 hell yeah my man my honey my boo it
never stopped
I'm supposed to kill you walking on crop
how much what is this oh the flame the
love of the Obsidian and what else the
gravel come on goddammit why do you guys
like me playing if I'm doing everything
wrong using no you to respond to an
insult using no you to respond to a
compliment oh damn I never thought of a
real minecraft veteran swords only real
gamers remember can we build a bridge
over the goddamn pain in this beam die
please thank you me and the boys
following Beauty pie oh yeah Peter pie
ends t-series Wars pity PI's analytics
F's in the chat boys everyone if peered
stop playing Minecraft after game when
we don't go I love you alright guys they
can be other memes as well like not mine
crack Jesus Christ petition for
PewDiePie to continue playing Minecraft
until he mines bedrock was bedrock
right-handed redditors trying to reach
the upload button circa a big dam yeah
well how are you gonna scroll you can't
scroll like that oh yeah this is how I
look dummies
fake posed down the boat 9 year olds
watching PD PI playing Minecraft the
wrong way PewDiePie I don't know what
I'm doing I am the veteran pay respect
oh you were in your dad's balls I was
making diamond pickaxes give me some
goddamn respect minecraft papers please
fortnight yeah you guys really didn't
like Fort nitrogen PD PI goes all the
way inside Belle Delphine marzia Pizza
time stop oh my god I can't believe
bailed elephant Richter's what number
one trending number one
trending I'm still worthy minecraft is
the game that brings me back
minecraft is gonna be my Redemption Ark
ill and musk waiting for his mom to get
off the phone to ask why his dolphin not
working this one sparks joy this one
sparks fire listen I'm not that bad of a
chef in real life okay I swear we'll put
that in the next episode happiness and
boyscout you guys are obsessed my name
Jurgen my sister went P deep I name this
horsy Argan wait there's people actually
named Jurgen cringe Swedish people
cutting down trees in Minecraft chip
chip
oh my god this it tho raise it it's chip
chip get it right
how do people have space for all I'm
just getting roasted what is things I
Spit on foreigners now this looks like
okay you're right huge scare to explain
I don't know boots crossing bridge we're
okay I uploaded my photo and got 350
likes only I got 400 amateurs what a pug
amateurs I don't get it PewDiePie it
legit everything in Minecraft and it's
after 2010 is this new boys in Minecraft
girls in Minecraft freakin horses oh my
god there's horses in playing hello tiny
why is the creeper living in the
daylight that makes no sense
creepers can live in daylight why's
cactus growing in my garlic god damn it
it looks like a cactus destroys mob
spawner dig straight down over diamond
that's it you've broken the laws I'm
taking you in please kitty farmer please
its gamer week if you die in your dream
you die in real life if you die in the
wrong game you don't respond if you die
in real life true intellectuals
me and the boys while my father buy the
ice cream for us that is so sweet
sir pewdiepie do Shawn
26 hours plus zoom for Easter eggs god
damn boy god damn look at that guy we're
gonna Italian leather damn look at the
detail 399 goddamn that is amazing
me review Andre that's amazing
petition to get diamond armor for uragan
wait you can give diamond armor to
horses that's awesome he looks slowly
getting better
alright remember the rules
check out merch game a week supreme and
let's freakin get their game or bread
bros thanks for this week's Lawai I see
you next week bye
what you never played super simulator
you know it's fun right I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]